you know what i realized this when i
started flying for like conventions and
stuff right
i was i always thought that airports
were even worse than they actually are
because right if you get one of those
package deals the
company that does the package deal
charges the plane right so you
all have to like wait in this [ __ ]
horrible line these planes are like the
[ __ ]
worst yeah and the people are the worst
as well it's like the worst kind of
british tourist
yeah which i'm sure you've all seen
videos of you watch like airport
meltdowns
it's always british people right always
dude these these [ __ ] flights are
awful man it's the most oh god you've
been on them
i've i've been on okay so the most
depressing place i've been to
on earth i think is luton airport oh
it's awful
or in uk in the uk yeah okay so we we
stayed
okay so this you know back back back
before
back when i was just like [ __ ] poor
and all that stuff
we uh we we booked this holiday um it
was
it was me it was me and sydney at the
time so we booked this holiday on this
like
budget airline that flew out of luton um
and i remember to save costs we needed
to stay near luton
because it was actually cheaper to stay
near luton than to like get there in the
morning in the
like rush hour right right and so we we
picked the cheapest hotel
which happened to be easy hotel which i
didn't know that already sounds soft
okay so so in like europe there's this
there's this budget airline called
easyjet it's the one right
and it's the worst it's one of the worst
airlines i wouldn't say it's the worst
what's the worst ryan
i'd say right orion anything that flies
out luton is
automatically like horrible for me but
like um so we stay we're staying easy
it's an easy hotel and i've never felt
like i've paid to stay in a prison cell
before
until i until i stayed there so it was
like we go in
and there's literally like no windows
yeah it's just it's just a white room
right
yeah no it's yeah i was just ours it's
just a black room and like the walls are
paper thin and they're like i could hear
at least like three different people
[ __ ] in different rooms
you know what i mean and i go into the
shower
right it's a shared shower right or is
it no no no no you you had your own
private shower
but it it was like wow that's one step
up but like but like there wasn't even
like
a door to like separate the shower from
like the bed
okay so you so it was it was just like
curtains so you open up these curtains
and then there is like a toilet seat
and then there is a shower right next to
it and it just
it was the like definition of how i
imagine a prison shower to be right
because the only thing said that because
there's nothing separating the toilet
from the shower right so so you just
you're just showering
and yes and and so while you're
showering the toilet's just like
getting [ __ ] soaked yeah and
everything like that and it's it's got
like the gray
kind of like kind of like floor as well
so it
it felt like i was in a prison cell and
i i had to pay good money how much was
it for like a night i can't remember
like 20 quid a night oh [ __ ] hell
yeah yeah i would have rather stayed in
a cab
like i just like i it was just like me
and sydney there but i was like
i better not drop the soap man i better
not drop the soap while i'm here
some dude just burst through the walls
like yeah
right ryanair and easyjet if you like
forget your ticket they charge you like
50 euros
i i got charged that when we flew from
uh [ __ ]
amsterdam to ireland as well did you
yeah i wanna i've never wanted to smack
an attendant in my life but
when she said that i was like my hand is
my backhand is ready
yeah and like if you have like over like
five kilograms or something which is
like what you're obviously gonna have
over
yeah they charge you like 50 pounds to
bring a carry on
it's ridiculous it's so dumb it's it's
awful daddy because it's right in this
fine print where
they they tell you you can't check in
right yeah and i think that's the big
one i like i
i can i understand you know not not
having like not be able to check in
or everything but like putting it in
like the fine prints
that's just a dick move yeah it is it is
like what what is it like [ __ ]
designs yeah
that is it that is and they have like a
million ads
before you even get to you know what you
want to like get to like
the amount of [ __ ] renter cars they
[ __ ] try and show you is up the ass
online
yeah and also even if the plane is
completely empty they won't let you
choose seats and they on purpose scatter
you
so that you fought they force you to pay
to sit next to each other right but i'm
like [ __ ] that yeah no i'm not doing
that [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
i'll see them when i land who [ __ ] cares
i'm not i'm not desperate that i need to
be within a two meter radius of my
friends all the time
jesus christ we have something like we
have something similar in australia it's
called jetstar
and every every [ __ ] like continent
has that that's so bad i
[ __ ] flew jetstar once from sydney to
brisbane and it was like an
hour and a half flight but it's the
worst [ __ ] flight i've ever been on
god
like delayed three hours for no reason
and then you get there and then it's
like 60 million years for the luggage to
come out on the other side i'm just like
where is this luggage it's like it's
like uh you've been on norwegian
you've been on norwegian i've been i've
been on [ __ ] hate norwegian airlines
that's all right
it's not norwegian's okay like compared
to other budget airlines norwegian is
like the rolls royce of budget airlines
man
no it's because it's the only budget
airline there's like long haul i sure
and you can do you can have a 12 hour
flight and they will give you
no food really yeah on noise you have to
pay for this oh
yeah yeah but like and any any budget
airline that has
movies that has a movie choice it's
already
like better than 90 percent of the fight
i think it only has movies because
they don't make those planes the ones
that do long haul without them built in
yeah i don't think they do that anymore
like so i don't think it's possible i'm
sure if they could have removed the tvs
and made you pay for them i'm sure they
would
yeah but like the fact that they can
they can go 12 hours and not give you
food
like blows my mind i've never been on
norwegian nail and don't that long
yeah i mean i i'd say i've i've been on
worse and and also it's a 12-hour flight
right and they try and they charge you
for like a carry-on where were you where
the [ __ ] were you flying to la to uk
uk and it's always norwegian because
they were by far the cheapest
you guys didn't have like american or
united are there's america yeah but yeah
so they were more like so
double the price also broke as [ __ ] so
it was like either norwegian which was
pretty consistently always like 400
bucks
yeah jesus from london to l.a
and then the next app was like united
which is like 500. but back then it's
like a hundred bucks i was like that's a
big deal yeah that's like
a slightly better hotel no it wasn't 400
to 500 it was like 400 to 600
600 700 yeah i i think you got what you
paid for
um i i i think that norwegian is good
for the price
and if you're like if you're like a
someone broke
who's trying to go to like ax or
something yeah or trying to go to la for
four years
i saw that you could pay for a meal but
i was like oh they'll give you like a
snack or something
yeah nothing you'll get anything you get
nothing would you like would you like
this granola bar for
six dollars and like these chests i
don't know how
it's like they've engineered these
chairs to be [ __ ] god-awful
like at least other airlines have
semi-competent chairs but for some
reason on norwegian airlines they'd
[ __ ]
handcrafted this [ __ ] to be disgusting
and painful
and if you get in the middle row of the
four it's like just just give up on
being happy in life for the next 12
hours and one time i went on it
and there was a i was on the i was in
the the end the aisle seat
of the three i was like okay well it's
not the middle of the four so yeah i'm
happy
and this couple were like making out
next to me like i swear they were
fingering each other
because i was like this is disgusting
like i wanna i wanna i wanna die
please please and no amount of like
don't look at the side could like
focus me on game of thrones season four
wherever the [ __ ] i was watching i was
like please
please please yeah because it's like
it's the one time you curse that you
have a periphery right yeah because the
one every time i would take my headphone
off just for a second i could hear like
oh i'm like oh god oh why
tell you what if you're gonna go in at
budget airlines just pay 300 bucks for a
good pair of noise counting headphones
like
honestly like that's the best advice i
can give you don't cheap out on them
jesus christ
like i don't know what it is about the
airplane design of seats
that are just like ergonomically
designed to be the most
uncomfortable thing you've ever sat on
did you see those standing seats they
were trying to make
no it's like to fit more people in
they're trying to make standing seats
for airlines so that like they can fit
more people it's basically like this
at this at this point what's the
difference between that and just being
cattle you know what i mean
like would just be literally being
herded in it was
obviously the budget airlines trying to
do this it's like [ __ ] sardines
yeah yeah they were like we can fit 20
more passengers in the economy if we
if we yeah but but no one wants that
yeah because no passengers
because their argument was something was
that if it's a two-hour flight you can
stand for two hours
not but no i don't want to no no no no
no it's terrible
it's [ __ ] what's that i don't mind a
one-hour flight i'm like whatever but
like when it's 12 hours sometimes having
a bad seat
even a prison transport system has seats
guys come on they do
the prison bus you can sit down yeah
yeah come on now
it's yeah it's sad man yeah but the
point was is that yeah now that i'm
older i'm grateful that my parents took
me on
vacation but when i was a kid now i'm
older i'm glad i have disposable income
yeah back to the thinking back to the
broke uni student days you know what i
mean